what's it like to all of a sudden look  up and say i'm the hottest act in the  world i don't think of myself that way  that's very nice i'm very very grateful  for all the success uh from my first  record  and um  i just feel like i have so much work to  do and i have so many more songs on the  album that i want to get out there and  i'm writing new material and i am  performing and i just want to keep going  once you reach a certain point it's like  people assume that oh now you're there  and and you're good you've have success  but the truth is that i want to do this  forever so uh you know it doesn't matter  if i'm number one now i want to be  number one for the next 10 years